well let's just start by reminding
ourselves where europe's gas natural gas
actually comes from and here you can see
it's uh primarily from russia in fact it
kind of really sticks out there doesn't
it then norway then algeria but of that
russian gas let's just kind of break
down where that is going to so we'll
take that bar and what we'll do is we'll
break it down among the different
countries that are getting that gas and
there is again one that really sticks
out here it's germany actually let me
put them side by side so you can see
just how big some of those slices are
germany by far and away the biggest then
italy then turkey netherlands france and
others and it is when this within this
others category that poland and bulgaria
are to be found so not enormous but
still significant from their perspective
and what has actually happened here well
at the moment those gas payments are
going from poland and bulgaria to russia
in euros and russia has said no we don't
want it in euros we want it in rubles as
well that's the symbol for the ruble and
poland and bulgaria have said no and
essentially that's what's caused a bit
of a rise in the gas price so this is
gas price in the netherlands it went up
by about 20 percent which is is big by
the scheme of you know previous years
but as you can see we've had such a
rocky ride recently in gas markets that
that isn't that enormous why is it not
that enormous well it's partly because
people are looking at poland and they're
looking at charts like this one this
shows you the amount of storage that
they have in poland gas storage in
previous years because it goes down in
the winter and then up in the spring and
the summer and look at where they are
this year so that's previous years this
year you can see they've got a lot more
gas in storage than in previous years
it's almost like they knew something was
coming it's worth also looking at the
pipeline network that we have around
europe of course there's lots of pipes
that are taking this gas mostly uh from
russia into europe um and poland at the
moment they're building new liquid
liquefied natural gas terminals
basically means that gas can be shipped
in uh by the coast that means they don't
rely on these pipelines quite as much
you've got in bulgaria new pipelines
coming in from greece that are taking
gas from azerbaijan so you're swapping
as vagina gas
for russian gas and then there's a kind
of broader point which is about these
pipelines you've got let's just focus on
two of them this is the nordstrom
pipeline it takes gas directly into
germany you've got the yamaha europe
it's a set of pipelines taking it from
russia into poland and have a look at
the flows in that polish that yamaha set
of pipelines they've been really low
recently so poland can kind of afford uh
with having fewer gas coming out of
russia but it's a different story when
you look at the gas going into the
nordstrom pipeline going into germany
germany massively reliant on russian gas
even now which takes us back to where we
started this chart what does germany do
now do they start paying in rubles what
about italy what about turkey the next
few weeks are going to be very
interesting indeed